we're going to the desert now
hello my internet friends we are here at
the mojave desert and behind me is the
white knight 2 the first consumer-based
space shuttle now if you have an extra
200 000 or so
you might be one of the lucky few that
get to go up on this thing
all right so i'm here with richard and
we just talked about the launch of the
white knight two now this is probably an
extremely exciting time for you
ah it's um i just had a baby
and she's very beautiful and not quite
as beautiful you but she's very
beautiful
and then
it's a very exciting day and
uh we still got a couple more years of
hard work um we need in the middle of
here the spaceship which is under a
shroud in there to be added um we're
only about 18 months away from going off
into space and taking other people into
space here
of all the brands in the world apart
from vegetables
that i have the greatest respect for
it's apple and um anyway they're
fortunate they're not going to space
travel yet so that's that is true that's
true i mean you know i got the new
iphone so that's you know that's
probably going to be
mine's bigger than you that's bigger
than that's bigger